the great resignation is continuing to
lose there are more than 11 million
unfilled jobs right now we hear from
businesses all over the country that
it's very hard to hire people
almost two years into the pandemic
workforce participation remains slumped
while job openings are near record highs
and this is coming at a time when the
recruiting process is going through a
radical transformation
companies in the past were maybe getting
dozens of applicants for a single
vacancy now they're getting hundreds
maybe even thousands of applications and
so software has come in to automate the
process of looking through all of these
different candidates if you've applied
for a job in the last five years you've
probably been impacted by this
technology whether it was screening your
resume making you play games to analyze
your personality making you go through
some other automated system
and some people are fighting back who's
accountable when those ai machines break
the law why it's important that congress
take action to ensure that big tech is
held accountable they claim there's
labor shortages but there's a plethora
of people out there who are looking for
jobs we're at a moment of growing crisis
with ai hiring and that's why people are
eager to act
amidst this whirlwind of disruption one
has to ask the question how do we go
from this
to this
[Music]
more than a decade ago instead of just
replying to a job in a newspaper
printing out hundreds of resumes and
sending them out physically to companies
now you can apply to even more companies
all at once by doing it over the
internet if you hate going to work and
your co-workers don't respect you hey
dummy it's probably time you need a new
job companies now they're getting
hundreds maybe even thousands of
applications and so software has come in
to automate the process of looking
through all of these different
candidates effectively using something
called ats or applicant tracking systems
these systems effectively track
different applicants look through their
resumes and take them even potentially
through the whole process they will take
candidates who are at the top the middle
and the bottom of performers as deemed
by a particular company or hiring
company and then train their systems
based on those judgments and then use
that as a baseline on which to make its
own automated judgments about whether
someone is good or bad
not just students experienced
professionals they just they just don't
know that these tools are used so
frequently
gracie sarkisian runs new york
university's career center where she
gives tips to optimize applications for
ai systems students will encounter ai
tools in an interview if they're doing a
virtual interview some folks will also
encounter ai-powered assessments as part
of their interview process depending on
the industries in which they're entering
the use of the software is very
prevalent there was a recent harvard
business study that came out showing
nearly every single one of the fortune
500 companies use this kind of software
large companies are never going to be
able to stop using this they just have
no choice because of the inbound flood
of applicants they get every single day
most vendors position their software as
something that can alleviate the human
bias which has shown to be endemic to
the hiring process
but critics question whether ai is
actually injecting fairness or just
making those same biases more efficient
i definitely think there is a segment of
the population that is being excluded or
not
fully represented
and they are being left to the wayside
this is jamal eggleston he's a work
readiness instructor at the hope program
a non-profit that helps new yorkers find
jobs
my students aren't prepared for it and
coming from the population
that might not be again as familiar with
the technology they run into pitfalls
and they they don't do as well as other
communities when encountering this these
ai
since u.s companies don't have to
disclose when they're using ai many
applicants are still writing resumes
catered to the human eye rather than to
ai
when people tell you that you should
dress up your accomplishments or should
use non-standard resume templates to
make your resume stand out when it's in
a pile of resumes that's awful advice
the only job your resume has
is to be comprehensible to the software
or robot that is reading it because that
software or robot is going to decide
whether or not a human ever gets their
eyes on it
ian siegel runs ziprecruiter one of the
dozens of ai companies which transform
the job hunt in recent years
you want to write your resume for robots
not for humans these softwares not only
review them to decide who gets passed to
a human but another thing they do is
they write simple summaries of who you
are for those humans so that those
humans may in fact never see your actual
resume
and it's not just resume screening
that's changed initial job interviews
and assessments are being automated at
companies like goldman sachs delta
airlines and walmart
this screen may look familiar you have a
minute or two to answer questions or
play an assessment game which will
determine whether or not you move on to
the next round
so we decided to try out one of these
systems for ourselves talk about a time
when i was overwhelmed or stressed then
employee who um's working style and my
management styles were not in sync
all right playing the first game it's
kind of like a remembering memorizing
four
six
seven and you have to okay so it's like
pattern recognition
okay
maybe i'm not getting the job i don't
know how much this is going to tell
about a person
what okay your assessment has been
submitted please click the button above
to continue
while our tests were unscored many
companies algorithmically rank
interviews based on word choice vocal
tone and facial expression
a lot of people are missing out a lot of
people are not giving back what the
interviewer is looking for because it
was programmed a certain way these
things are programmed by a certain
segment of the population that might not
be totally inclusive or not be
fully aware of how other cultures emote
i believe race is a part of it i know
it's trying to be uh trying to leave
race out of it i know it's trying to be
uh not biased but some things are
inherent uh even if it's unconscious
i like to call it the ghost in the
machine
in a statement higher view said its
systems are rigorously audited for
adverse impact meet all regulations and
only analyze word choice
last year the company announced it
discontinued facial analysis in part
over bias concerns
applicants trying to navigate this new
world of hiring find themselves looking
for help on social media this is how to
be automated resume screening software
here's how to trick the online job
application if you know how to play the
game you're actually able to stand out
on top as the best candidate one
controversial strategy is copying an
entire job description into your resume
hidden with white font in order to trick
the ai into picking up keywords
they won't be able to see that you have
all of those qualifications and is
exactly what they have on their website
because it's all white
it's eventually going to go to a human
being that's going to look at that
resume and say this is ridiculous it's
not about beating the system i think
that that that thinking is not going to
help candidates to be most successful
what helps you be most successful in the
job search is to know that the world of
work is always changing there are tech
vendors that help candidates optimize
their resume for systems we have a tool
that we use at nyu other universities
use it it's called vmock students can
put their resume into the system and it
will give them a score and one of the
things that it's scoring for is how
likely it will be to be picked up by an
ats for a particular industry
while elite universities have access to
resume optimizing tech others may be
left behind in this new world of work
there are millions of people
who are being left out of the job market
because hiring software is discounting
them very early on on the process when
it scans their resumes we have students
who some had belts with incarceration
some of our students are college
students some of our students are
long-term workers who have been laid off
because of the pandemic and these are
good people who have great experiences
who can add and become assets to a lot
of these companies for example a person
who perhaps spent some time in the
military
or someone who went on parental leave
might have a year or two long gap in
their resume now if you were going to
interview with a human being you might
be able to explain why that gap is there
but an algorithm doesn't necessarily see
that it just sees that between a couple
of years you weren't working a lot of
times they get no response and it's
really hard because they're they
they don't know what they did wrong they
don't know if they did anything wrong
there's this term the black box of
artificial intelligence what's happening
with some of these algorithms is they
might be discounting hundreds of
different types of people but even the
people who create the software don't
know why
in a statement isims one of the leading
ats vendors said it takes these concerns
seriously and has a team focused on
responsible ai and follows industry
initiatives on fairness
algorithmic discrimination is difficult
to prove but it's been revealed by
audits
amazon scrapped its ai recruitment tool
in 2018 after it discriminated against
applications which listed women's
colleges or sports in another system the
best predictors of job performance
included being named jared or having
played high school lacrosse according to
an auditing law firm the algorithms that
are being used to
look at people's resumes to conduct
interviews they've been trained on data
about previous applicants over perhaps
the past decade that's how machine
learning works
no one explicitly told these systems to
discriminate but they were trained on
millions of biased hiring decisions the
fear with these algorithms is that you
take bias data in because they're using
the wisdom of the crowd and the crowd is
clearly biased and what you're really
doing is perfecting bias that's the
accusation that's been made
the reality is that when we deploy these
algorithms we as the software engineers
and programmers get to make choices
about what data the algorithm can and
cannot use we can say to the algorithm
you never get to see someone's name if i
tell you someone's name is jeremy levine
you know something about them if i tell
you somebody's name is natasha you know
something about them and by removing
them we create the most level playing
field we possibly can so as much as
possible it's a merit-based system
while automated hiring tools have become
ubiquitous public perception hasn't
caught on recent pew surveys found that
most americans didn't know resumes are
being screened by computers and most
considered the practice unacceptable but
one crucial group is paying attention to
ai lawmakers the european union has
unveiled its proposed strategy for
artificial intelligence including
regulations on transparency and data
protection concerns about how this
technology could exacerbate
discrimination
for the ftc i think foremost the ftc
needs to be making sure that we're fully
understanding this technology
a federal civil rights agency is
scrutinizing automated hiring tools
while illinois and dc have explored some
of the nation's first ai hiring
regulations the federal trade commission
recently gave a message to companies
using ai hold yourself accountable or be
ready for the ftc to do it for you in
new york we just enacted one of the
first ai hiring regulations in the
country albert vox khan runs a
technology advocacy group and
participated in new york's task force to
understand the impact of ai systems
the bill basically started off by saying
before you sell this technology you'll
have to do an audit and you'll have to
tell people when this technology has
been used and when you look at what this
bill did
it was regulation name only having an
audit can be useful but when that audit
is done by the software vendor
themselves well that's not worth the
paper it's written on and it's absurd
but in the new york law you can't sue it
doesn't matter how egregious the
software is it doesn't matter how biased
you don't get your day in court and
without that
none of these bills can work
in response some of the world's largest
companies like ibm and facebook parent
meta have devised an auditing standard
for ai and hiring however
critics say that industry standards
can't replace true government regulation
we don't trust companies to
self-regulate when it comes to pollution
we don't trust them to self-regulate
when it comes to workplace comp why on
earth would we trust them to
self-regulate ai look i think a lot of
the ai hiring tech on the market is
illegal i think a lot of it is bias i
think a lot of it violates existing laws
the problem is you just can't prove it
not with the existing laws we have in
the united states so a big part of this
is playing catch-up to open up discovery
to open up the court process to say you
can look at these algorithms more easily
with widespread adoption the use of ai
hiring tools is less the future of work
and more like the present virtual
assessments interviews and job
applications likely aren't going
anywhere but it's up to the employers to
decide how much of their process they
really want to automate
smaller companies have a little bit more
choice here because they don't get as
many applicants as the big companies do
so one thing that's been suggested to me
by people in the recruitment industry is
actually maybe the small to medium-sized
businesses should just be a little bit
more
critical in their thinking of whether
they really want to use this software
because in some cases just using a human
being to interview someone even to look
through all the resumes might stand a
better chance of finding that star that
star employee that they're looking for
keep a segment or a avenue open
for an older person for a person who was
incarcerated for a person who's young
for a person who's just not aware of
these technologies so they can also have
an opportunity to to get hired we can't
solely base
something as important as finding a job
as finding a career
to only to ai it's hard to fight against
something that has been programmed one
way or the other we can only teach our
students how to navigate these waters
you